[Musica]
[Applauso]
comincia dicendo che sono stato invitato
qui a questa serata da mattia cotoni col
quale ho potuto scambiare solo
solo a distanza in un carteggio senza
averlo potuto conoscere personalmente e
quindi a lui dedico questa mia
presentazione allora le la tecnica è da
sempre a mio parere una mediazione degli
umani con la natura e la società e come
tutte le costruzioni sociali e
attraversata da contraddizioni
biforcazione conflitti ora io vorrei
focalizzare soprattutto su un periodo
che in un periodo di passaggio fra
diciamo l'era industriale e quello che
ho chiamato capitalismo cognitivo cioè
l'era attuale che è basata sulla
economia della conoscenza e sui dieci
anni in cui emersero due grandi
tecnologie che cambiarono le
soggettività e sono internet e la
telefonia mobile ma facciamo prima un
salto nel tempo e andiamo a berkeley
ambita cioè la grande università
californiana nella metà fra degli anni a
cavallo fra gli anni 60 e 70
e qui emergono due fenomeni
apparentemente non collegati che sono da
un lato nei laboratori di ricerca
studenti ricercatori professori
sviluppano a partire di un sistema
operativo open source unix che poi è un
progenitore di lui di linux
i protocolli di rete che sono ancora
oggi quelli che fanno funzionare
internet e dall'altro lato sempre quelle
università emerge questa protesta contro
la guerra del vietnam per me che ero
quell'epoca studente del politecnico a
milano in informatica agli inizi
dell'informatica è sembrato a me è
sembrato che ci fosse un collegamento
fra questi due avvenimenti
che di fatto era una generazione che da
un lato quale va esprimeva a qualcosa
una protesta contro la guerra che poi si
diffonde in tutto il mondo e dall'altro
cercava dei modi di comunicazione
orizzontale non gerarchica
ecco quindi da qui nascono rinascere
quel movimento che poi da un lato il
movimento hacker e dall'altro si è anche
la costruzione del free software che
cambia le regole di etica della
produzione e per esempio l'autonomia del
lavoro la creatività tecnica e diventano
dei valori la libera circolazione delle
informazioni diventano dei valori che si
oppongono a quella che era la vecchia
etica capitalista protestante delle
dell'epoca weber jana che diceva che il
profitto era una grazia divina di cui
non bisognava utilizzare i frutti e
quindi in questo senso credo che ci sia
stato un passaggio storico anche della
produzione sociale e oggi i free
software che ha determinato una nuova
giurisdizione che quel delle quattro
libertà di utilizzare copiare modificare
diffondere è stato fondamentale
ma i grandi progetti non sono
completamente uniformi per esempio nel
grande progetto linux che è alla base
del dl di di internet ci sta una come
dire un un'equipe che formata da
salariati a 80 per cento salariate di
grandi multinazionali mentre wikipedia è
molto meno legata a valori commerciali e
finanziari adesso vediamo sulle
soggettività
il cellulare è secondo me la telefonia
mobile per saltare all'altra all'altra
grande rivoluzione della telefonia
mobile è una delle più grandi
rivoluzioni tecnologiche nel tempo nel
senso che è stata fulminea e 20 30 anni
quasi tutti gli umani hanno questo
medium individuale che non richiede
conoscenze particolari per essere
utilizzata e quindi sotto un certo punto
di vista è anche un dispositivo che
serve per decorare la vita biologica e
in questo senso che amato b e per media
la parola che è una confluenza di
biopolitica ipermedia l'insieme questo
questa nuvola e quindi qua vediamo alle
nuvole questa nuvola che ci avvolge di
tutti i dispositivi mobili tecnici
l'internet degli oggetti con i quali
entriamo in un'interazione continua che
e multisensoriale che crea una
integrazione quasi una simbiosi dei
nostri corpi con la globe e siglò
globale complessiva rete elettronica e
questo ha cambiato le soggettività
sicuramente fa circolare le idee e nuove
idee passano attraverso questa nuvola
però serve anche in certi casi come
forma di assoggettamento sociale come
forma di asservimento macchi nico
guardate per esempio come questo ha
cambiato le l'attenzione qual è la
difficoltà i millennials ma di tutti noi
qual è la difficoltà di di concentrarsi
che c'è oggi
guardate come questi strumenti e queste
applicazioni possano diventare qualcosa
di compulsivo per spingerci a un a
pagare i desideri nel consumismo
guardate come bring on your hand di vice
è una espressione che venne fondata
qualche anno fa per dire che il
lavoratore deve portare il suo
dispositivo e la sua capacità di
utilizzarlo sul lavoro guardate come
questo è diventato anche una norma nei
lavori precari come i ciclisti di di
food ora agli autisti di huber
ma passiamo a neuro capitalismo che
neuro capitalismo elevandosi un attimo è
che josè è per me la strategia che in
parte nasce a silicon valley di
sviluppare algoritmi
e applicazioni che hanno la capacità di
manipolare la neuroplasticità umana
e poi questo è adottato da tutti noi o
quasi come una specie di servitù
volontaria perché sono oggetti molto
interessanti e attraenti però è in
realtà a mio parere
qua siamo in una in algoritmi come dice
lo stesso zuckerberg il fondatore di
facebook che ci racconta che in pratica
loro sviluppano delle componenti e di
intelligenza artificiale per controllare
tutto il significato di quello che passa
su facebook
circa un terzo dei messaggi pericolosi
vengono identificati da queste
componenti di intelligenza artificiale e
per zuckerberg
il fine è quello di come dire combattere
il terrorismo globale o addirittura
prevenire i problemi prima che che
avvengano ma questa mi sembra una
distopia come nel vecchio film di
spielberg minority report
e noi io personalmente critico il fatto
che il capo di una società privata si
arroghi questo questo diritto
quindi per passare sul lato velocemente
sul lato della filosofia qui si combaci
sono due grandi tendenze che usano la
tecnologia nel posto umanesimo alla
figura centrale è il cyborg che dovrebbe
secondo i portatori di questa filosofia
come rosi braidotti per esempio dovrebbe
essere la figura che riesce a cambiare
l'era dell'antropocene cioè l'epoca in
cui stiamo influendo sulla
sull'equilibrio ecologico del
dell'ecosistema nella maniera negativa
che sappiamo
quindi sto parlando a taranto e sapete
di che cosa cosa intendo
d'altro lato del transumanesimo invece è
una è un movimento filosofico più legato
a silicon valley che vede nella
tecnologia qualcosa per prolungare alte
al limite anche in termini definiti la
vita umana cioè praticare ad esempio
queste visioni tecnologiche del mind
uploading cioè il la copia della mente
al di là del corpo e nel francia nel
paese dove vivo questo è stato molto
criticato psicologi e psichiatri dicono
che qualsiasi visione in cui l'uomo
diventa immortale onnipotente foriera di
gravi tecnologie di gravi scusate di
gravi patologie
lo spirito dei common e quello che un po
ho citato anche nel parlando dei
movimento a che di questi nuovi valori
ma soprattutto è lo spirito che è capace
di utilizzare le tecnologie in una
ottica che è alternativa per rispetto
alla mercificazione rispetto alla
privatizzazione che sono valori
abbastanza dominanti oggi a mio parere e
cito solo due
due esempi ma potrei cominciare a citare
già uno degli esempi mi è stato dato
proprio qui con la radio no border in
cui le tecnologie vengono usate in
un'ottica differente
oppure nell'ambito della schering
economy che ancora oggi effettivamente
dominata dalle grandi mega macchine
delle piattaforme mondiali c'è un
movimento che cercano di utilizzare
queste applicazioni come in una forma
come strumento del comune in una forma
diversa
oppure anche la tecnologia del bitcoin
che pure è molto ambivalente perché
usato come moneta di speculazione questa
tecnologia
ci sono esperimenti di moneta del comune
ci sono esperimenti e di gestione dei
beni comuni
quindi sono aperture e speranze che
possono che esistono grazie alla
tecnologia l'intelligenza robotica bene
abbiamo se ne discute un tema che è
molto il tema che la robotizzazione
credo che è stato menzionato anche prima
che la robotizzazione sta avanzando sia
dal punto di vista della produzione
materiale anche gli iphone per non
citarli in c.da vengono prodotti sempre
di più attraverso dei robot e sia nei
servizi pensate per esempio alla
logistica e quindi a tutte le macchine
che manchino i trasporti che funziona
funzioneranno più o meno automaticamente
tutto questo porta molti a dire che la
visione che ci fa vedere il domani
nel domani lo stesso pieno impiego
salariato che c'è stato per esempio nel
nel secondo dopoguerra non è possibile e
fa emergere il discorso sul reddito
universale a cui fa riferimento questo
manifesto che è uscito durante il
referendum su questo tema che è tenuto
che è stato ottenuto in svizzera lo
stesso mark zuckerberg
ci ha detto che anche lui è d'accordo
sul reddito universale al punto che
alcuni gli hanno detto va bene se sei
d'accordo sul reddito universale allora
comincia a dare ai membri a quelli che
partecipano a facebook visto che estrae
del valore da facebook 80 euro al mese
non l'ho inventato io quindi questa è
come dire in questa in questo senso ci
sono sia dei movimenti sia delle realtà
di utilizzo delle tecnologie in un senso
diverso e termino con
una citazione di una recensione che c'è
stata sul mio libro che in risposta a un
articolo che era uscito su un quotidiano
nazionale che diceva va bene tutte
queste pratiche queste economiche
sociali diffuse virali sono molte
interessanti ma senza una strategia
politica non cambieremo le cose non non
creeremo un reale rapporto con
l'ecologia mondo per ritornare a un
equilibrio diverso e qualcun altro ha
risposto dicendo che sì è vero però
tutte queste pratiche sono quelle che
creano lupus la base dove fermentano le
resistenze che si oppongono all'aumento
dell'entropia e resistono a questa
sconfitta definitiva che sembra a
minacciarci grazie
[Applauso]